- Oh, here we go, we got more.
- Hey!
What's up, Ted and Annette?
Come on in.
Yes. Fangs for coming.
Have a bloody good time.
Awesome. Oh! Oh.
♪ Hee-hee! ♪
- There he is. What's up, Noah?
- Michael Jackson.
- Oh, here it is.
♪ Hee-hee! ♪
- Yeah, that's what he does.
- That's Michael Jackson.
- ♪ Hee-hee! ♪
- All right.
♪ Hee-ee hee! ♪
- Great!
- Ow!
- Nice.
♪ Ow! Sham! ♪
- Oh, there we go.
♪ Sham! ♪
- There we go.
- All right, three's the charm.
- ♪ Sham on! ♪
- Four.
- Ha!
- All right, well--
- Annie, are you okay?
- Oh! He's leaning.
He's leaning.
- Are you okay, Annie?
- All right.
- Are you okay?
- Annie, are you okay, Annie?
You've been touched
by a smooth criminal.
- Very nice Ha!
♪ Sham on! ♪
- Oh, more kicks.
- Ha! Closer! Closer!
- More kicks. You're--
- Close to your face!
- You... Ah!
You almost hit me there.
- You're really getting--
♪ Sham on! ♪
- No more "sham on"s.
- ♪ Hoo hoo! ♪
- You want to come inside?
That's annoying.
That is very annoy...
Stop. Stop! Just...
- Don't do it anymore.
- Ha!
- Yo!
- Great.
♪ Sham on! ♪
Just keep doing the sham on.
- That's the one--
- Where the children at?
♪ Hee! Hee! ♪
- "Where the children at?"
- ♪ Jesus juice. ♪
- That's in bad taste.
- Ho!
- This isn't...
- Thriller eyes.
♪ Sham on! ♪
- What... what are you doing?
♪ Jam it on! Jam it on! ♪
- No, you're cut of sham ons.
- I'm... oh, okay. Ha!
- He doesn't slap
his ass like that,
so I don't know what...
- Okay.
♪ Nah-nah-nah, nah-nah-nah...
nah-nah... ♪
- No, he doesn't...
I've never seen him
hit his ass...
- Hey. But no--
- O-oh!
- Hey... can we just... hey...
Hey, man...
Hey, stop... stop it! Stop it!
The [bleep] costume's awful,
The impression is stupid
and played out,
Everybody and their mother
was Michael Jackson
three years ago when he died!
- He died?
- Oh.
- Wait... wait, he died?
- Oh, Noah.
Oh, Noah...
♪ Boo hoo ♪
- What?
No, wait... wait a second.
Don't sad-moonwalk away.
♪ Mm, boo hoo ♪
You know what? Let...
♪ Boo hoo! ♪
- Happy Halloween.